Uh lets see here. I'll be a female please.
Hey it's Jesus everyone!  How's it going Bros?
To avoid any form of cultural appropriation,
I will be as white as possible.
So our audio options are: Jacksepticeye...
Woman: NYAAAAAA
Markiplier...
Woman: WOOOOAAAAAA *laughs*
And Pewdiepie.
Woman: Cut me down ;-;
Blonde...
White Hair! I can choose my own hair in games!
OHHH FINALLY.
I can associate with another character!
Wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-woah
Body features?
Breast size...
You know it's a good game, if there's a breast size slider and nothing else.
I mean what else would you really want to customize?
Unless thick-
OOOOOOOOOOOHHH
Here we are in the middle of the desert,
and we got... DAT ASS!
I don't know what you do in this game,
So this is another one of those survival games.
I mean we started of the game as Jesus so we can't be doing too bad.
Hopefully there's something to kill soon.
Oh wait so  giant- Ooooh my god.
Alright, just remembered I forgot my groceries.
Oh, look there's a guy here :>
Ah, I like how my tits are there if I stare down.
Oh, I got stone and shit!
And fibers!
Oh God, it's one of th-those games.
So far the best game, uuh- the best part of this game has been the boobs
I'm not gonna lie. Look at them.
Holy shit.
Ok, we have that, now, wha- does that mean we can cra-
WOAH, LOOK AT THAT, BOI
What does this do?
I'm sorry stone. Does this mean anything?
I have a feeling I'm not doing anything.
*UAHAAAAH*
You're punching a stone, woman.
I could just do this ALL day...
This is SOOOOO fun.
GREEAT, everyone!
How 'bout this one??
The fuck do I use this for then???
Alright, how do I get water, then?
How do I get WATER in a fucking desert??
You build a well, maybe?
WOOOAAAAAHHHH NO! I'M DYIIINNG! WOAH!
*woman grunts*
Ahahahaha *inhales*
You were killed by thirst....
For DAT ASS
Hey-There's one of those-- Fuckin'- Gargoyle things again.
Hey, listen here, buddy
You're not Batman! (Don't crush the beast's dreams, pewds)
You're not! You're just not. (No need to pour salt on the wound)
Hey-- Is this an oasis?
OKAY- Well this is a lot more fucking pleasant
Oh god, there's ANIMALS...
Where's the water? I need water.
wait- DERS ODAR HOOMANS (translation: Humans straight ahead)
What the fuck are they-- Oookay, nevermind.
I'm not- I won't go there.
I'm not gonna l-lose out on this fucking beautiful sp-- They're right behind me aren't they?
Goddam-
SAVE ME, TURTLE!
SAVE ME, TUUURTLE!
FUCKIN DO SOMETHING, TURTLE!
WATER
Perfect- perfect! Per-
Oh my gawd. Look, it's Jacksepticeye. (stop)
Water... The essence of life...
My god...
What a nice form of swimming...
Pfft-Haha!
OHMAHGAWD, you're soooo cute.
Ahaaaawwww
Hey look, eggs
I'll take 'em... (Eggcellent)
Mah eggs, muthafuckas.
Do I have to cook these?
ohmygod-- IT'S A FUCKING ALLIGATOR!
IT'S AN ALLIGATOR!
WHAT THE HELL, WHAT THE HELL!!?!
No no no no no no NOOO!
GODDAMN ALLIGATUH
Scared the shit outta me...
(Mocking) Alligators can't swim, haha!
Oh... my--
What just happened?
What the f-
What the fuck just happened?! (idk Pewds)
What the- YOU CAN'T JUST...
YOU CAN'T JUST DOO THAT!
For fuck's sake...
Hey how 'bout that all my progress lost...
...My favorite game.
EY IT'S A BUNNY KILL IT!
Fuck you bunny!
Come're bunny, come here-- I  need da food- I NEED FOOD.
eh- AHHHHHHHHHHH
*RIP HEADPHONE USERS*
Alright- Now we need to defend ourselves
That's right...
*frightened inhale*
*Swedish talk*
FUCKING ALLIGATOR, YOU'RE BACK!
REMATCH PLZ *gator
Gawdd fucking dammit!
This game is stressin' the hell outta me, I swear to god.
Now let's kill this bunny.
Fuck you, bunny!
OOOH!
My god!
NO! No! I'm sorry! I didn't know he was your friend!
Fuuuck!
Oh- I'm crippled now.
It's a fight to the death.
... It's a fight to the death.
Please die.
Please die!
Please diee!!!
OOOH- YESSS!
Survival of the fittest, mothahfuckah! *voice cracks*
How the fuck did that get up there?
How?
What are you doing up there? *Laughing during speech*
*Pewds imitating gazelle* Ahh! Stop, hey! Y-you got a ladeer?!
*Still Gazelle* I'm stuck up here, BOI
Halp meh, Poodiepie!
I will reward you... greatly
All right, where should we build a bed?
On a knife safe location.
Wait, that looks fuckin' awesome. Look at that bridge.
Lets go there.
Ooh no.
There's bunny!
Come on bunny!
Ooh, jav what the fuck?!
Stop fucking fucking with me
I'm tired of this! I'm tired of you! I'm ti-
Fuck you fuck you fuck OH MY GOD another one!
Oh this ass is real bad
NOOOOOOOOOO
Oh my god, there's a bunny again. This is my chance.
Come on bunny x2 BUNNY
BUNNY WOAAHH bunny flip hehehe
Oh shit- shit no
OOH oh why you do that Pewdiepie
*coff coff* I have a family *coff coff*
ayyyyyyy look!
It's Semi! Damn that ass though ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Fuck. Run.  Just run Felix.
Oh my fucking lord.  Oh my god. Oh-oh no.
Oh, you've done it now.
Oh you oh uh uh oh you've- oh *erection
Now let's build this motherfucking bed once and for motherfucking all
Now we have a spawn point, thank god.
OHH MY GOD STOP. DOING. THAT YOU PIECE OF SHIT
Fuck shit shit. . . shit
Shut the fuck- nope no. Not going to die today.
OH MY GOD
h-holy shiit
Yeah I get it. I'm dead, fuck me
Jesus fucking christ.
I swear to god- OH MY-
I. Hate. You. You fucking suck.
Hell yeah. I got a fucking shield boys. Hell yeah
I'm the King of the Nature, the Danger.
Ok, where's my fucking sword.
LOOK AT THAT BOIII
Still don't have pants, but don't worry about it.  I'll get pants
I'm coming for revenge.  I'm fucking ready boys
Fucking ready to kill
Anything in my sight
Ready
Never been this ready in ma life. MA LIFE
Oh my god.  On second thought, I think not.
Let's start with this motherfucker, here
This Jacksepticeye looking motherfucker.
Oh, he's got frands
Hey! Pst.
that's right.  That's right, whatcha gonna do.  Whatcha gonna do.
Whatcha gonna do, you evil doggo.
Evil dogger, fuck you!
*dying sound*
Bring it!
Fuck you x4
THATS RIGHT
I'M the King of the Jungle
Jesus H Christ, what is happening.  Are they talking to each other
"What the fuck you doing on my territory?!"
"Shut the fuck upp."
Oh my god, they're fast- ow
Fuck, I'm crippled.  I'm fucking crippled.
Land in the water.
Did it
It's really fun to play The Arch Reskinned, it's a really good game
*dink donk dink* Oh shit x4
I'm getting- oh shit
look at how many fuck-
What? Why did no one tell me.
This is how they used to do it in the medieval ages.
Just swing away, son.
Alright, here we go.  Where's ma fucking door
Did I craft the ceiling, yes I did x2
There's my- that's- there it is.
This is the best goddamn house.
This feels just like Minecraft.
Now I am protected from Creepers at night.
Does it get nighttime in this game?
YES! MY HOUSE.  MY HOUSE.
What the fuck are you doinnn *slice slice*
Doesn't even give a shit.
SMACK THAT ASS BOI.
Come on, I know you want it ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) Nope, alright then
Good bye.   Nevermind, I am here now.
DIEE, SON OF SATAN.  How are you not dead?
Why you do this (´；д；`)
What the fuck- Just, just stop.
Just stop.
In these survival games, you always get to this one point where it's like
Well, I know how to handle all of my stamina bars, I've gotten literally everything
Now, I guess I can. . . do something else?
I think I got him x2
Fuck
What the fuck?
Where's my bed?
WHERE'S MY FUCKING BED?!
Well, hope you enjoyed another gameplay.  It's been a while since we did one.
Let me know if you want to continue this series
Leave a like if you do, and as always, stay awesome bros!